- gum right my spam welcome back to some
more outlast DLC baby let's keep playing
baby hey baby twice what the way always
was sitting he was [ __ ]
oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't handle that
[ __ ] in here and then oh well that would
better than expected nailed that [ __ ] so
easy oh my gosh so fast the [ __ ] best
doing great press Friday oh not really
I'm kidding a man Oh
I'm sorry geyser hi there big fella
hi ed over there chap great talk great
our bet stock alright let's just move
this out of the way huh [ __ ] out of me
no I don't know what you're doing at hi
hi oh you know what after you gentlemen
after you sir alright well then great
talk best talk okay wonderful
all right yeah I'm just gonna you
breathe the really bad you should
probably check top what what was that I
missed something spoken didn't I hi bad
bro bro you got hello bro you got it
hello
okay I'm sure it's fine no all right
that's fine all right
and that's fine great all right he's
dead and that's a foot great time
goddamn let me in foot son of a [ __ ]
foot oh god is that [ __ ] again isn't it
oh no I don't like him Oh job Lana
please be nice to the little birds to
you what security I was I'm a patient
like you so these clothes from a dead
body I've been why how bad will be
promised to take me to this Lane I'll
talk to you then I don't have a choice
away alright fine I'll just have to
trust you oh wait this is great material
alright great ass well that was fun
let's do that again
hi what oh god it's that thing of a
[ __ ] plus it oh [ __ ] you I'll go in
here no one to find me here
hi can you blow my whistle ah Sarah I
don't know what I was supposed to do
there maybe I picked the wrong Locker
probably pick the wrong lacquer [ __ ]
Yolo which way this way yes Oh
[Applause]
oh now the nanny one I can barely handle
the one who nipple oh wait there's none
[ __ ] hey let me out was that was that
the exit oh my god I'm so unlucky well
you know what you know what I would
probably break those glasses and try to
squeeze through I know it would hurt but
I think it would hurt less and looking
at that god damn that sucks man that's
depressing
alright let's check this out
love this ELC so far it's pretty damn
epic am I supposed to go up here huh
it kind of feels again okay if I'm here
cool gray times best times the best
times weird pills yes when he's drinking
is so hard we get
all right that's great
Great Physician today in because then I
can do this kind of [ __ ] I'm need a
reload which button do I reload with
again it's not our oh they got Pepsi
over here
ah [ __ ] every time get down this is dark
here we go I like this place now I can
do this
man I look high alright
I like this place it's cozy alright cozy
alright someone just take a [ __ ] well
what is he doing
what the [ __ ] is he doing Oh God
it's a candy Bale I can't bail I can't
see can you eat over here please
from what what it what does that mean hi
ah I can't kiss you I'm sorry uh I got
damnit that's a bummer
well you can't have everything a knife
Oh what are we cooking today ah some
nice fingertips oh wow they must be
celebrating something okay they're all
missing their heads except this guy
what's your story good job not as a fine
float for what okay I got you on tape
you got me on TMZ [ __ ] what are you
doing what are you doing that that's oh
oh that you microwave his [ __ ] head
that's genius
how does he oh oh nice oh boy oh wait
what hello I'm a person leave the
college week batteries when the monix
gone and you can't go on okay I need to
reload there we go now we'd work with
our I don't know why I need for it okay
alright that's the [ __ ] and this is
where I want to oh no oh no no no no no
no no no oh no no no run run run run run
run run run run run get your [ __ ] out of
my way [ __ ] I think he's gonna die is
he dead yet you see that yet I don't
have a cheese bra am I supposed to get a
pair of keys I can't call my god oh my
god I can't believe I did see that
alright let's go in here boom oh god
okay
Oh our insist of psychopaths wanting to
eat meat that's every Tuesday for me
throwback Thursday what it doesn't make
sense
all right wait a minute out of life what
a great tell by everything about your
experience here Chang great fun loved it
loved it oh god is that [ __ ] here again
I am that guy with her
oh god he's naked [ __ ]
hi oh [ __ ]
I don't think he heard me I see
can you blow by with no I'm not no I'm
not
you didn't hear [ __ ] you Yolo
[ __ ] that's right yes that
one's really well
Oh God reload reload I don't [ __ ] up
reload I don't have time for this
oh [ __ ] I can't see anything oh god oh
god oh god I don't it's gonna be ok it's
gonna be ok it's gonna be ok I'm gonna
find me you can't find me Oh oh god he's
still checking he's not gonna check me
by not eating me I'm not delicious I eat
a lot of junk food Oh Polly tastes like
it
Oh God all right he's gone
let's read okay first step reload this
[ __ ] why don't you want to do that I
don't understand batteries for the
bottom thumb can't go won't batteries I
wanted another marathon all night long
and batteries what all right easy easy
it's just a [ __ ] why are you being a
[ __ ] though it's close this door you
never know what kind of strangers might
have been didi hello Birds oh we got
here
she was by the [ __ ] hat I have ever
seen we are looking for some Hank ups
and stuff it bothers me that we are
gonna have to go back later it bothers
me a line
what Oh baby
it's the one I yes whoa Oh food me no no
I don't wanna know
shut up I don't like you you may have a
great ass oh [ __ ] tight all right
let's go away not like who all right
that went great
now let's reload this [ __ ] can't do
that understand don't like this at all
not one bit nope
don't like this at all don't want to do
that again
nope I don't want to do with that soda
nope I can't why - oh it's fun
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks so much
he doesn't see me
[ __ ] [ __ ] what am I supposed to go
it's not [ __ ] fair
Oh what about in here
Isis camp here
we're cool we're cool we got this no
problem no problem nope
Eddie never did know
it's so tempting I don't know why all
right
this is wait here I'm sure we're safe
here I don't like you at all
hi
oh no oh no that's very vain that is
very may open you [ __ ] dick holding
the pace bras I am so sorry but I have
to end this episode here but I still
hope you enjoyed watching and watching
me suffer you got em sadist I'm kidding
I still love you
All Right see you tomorrow boys
[Music]